meine heilige königin was halten sie
davon dass alle leute mir immer zu
unrecht unterstellt ich hätte das ja da
geklaut und das da
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge microsoft excel auf dem
webserver wir gehen mal ganz kurz
treffen klicken
ich hoffe keiner stelle debitor wenn man
frieden mit gut so gut ich wollte in
dieser folge ein wenig mein haus ein
bisschen ich wollte dass er so ein
bisschen weiß nicht wie wir das
eigentlich machen bräuchte es anders
machen
ich wollte es auf jeden fall wollte ich
das großartig was anderes machen ich
habe da er letztes mal nicht so heftig
daran gebaut weil das ja hier alles
worum geschmeckt hat hat dich pläne
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich pläne hatte
ich kann immer schauen was ich noch so
alles verzaubern kann so jedenfalls
wollte ich über ein thema reden und zwar
etwas fast in den letzten videos immer
öfter darunter stand ach ja ich wollte
die essensausgabe weiterbauen richtig
naja gut und zwar etwas was in den
letzten videos immer wieder unter dem
video stand und zwar keine hitze voll
nachgemacht
bei dem defekt beispielsweise in der
herbstsession vorgestellt richtig druck
von dir machst alles nach und so
richtige richtiger bullshit einfach nur
da dachte ich mich dass ich mich dazu
jetzt mal ganz kurz äußere weil da ich
auch oft immer zu recht auch verteidigt
werde von eurer seite was ich auch cool
findet wer dann irgendwelche ankommen
meistens haben sie dann noch einnahmen
wie ihn was mit wwe geklaut dann auch
noch von irgendeiner serie was ball
eigentlich dann gar nicht mehr ab als
der copyright sachen sind dann irgendein
bild wo man sieht dass die zwölf jahre
alt sind und sich irgendwie dann weiß er
nichts sagen
also das ist eine kleine auslass folge
darüber beziehungsweise
erklärungsversuch wieder zusammen zu
heiße aber es trägt einen echtheits
schon auf also
was ich mache diese fact serie und
peceny accepted was auch dazu komme ich
aber gleich
aber ich mache diese effect serie
minecraft fact serie mache ich seit weiß
ich nicht wann die ersten folge kamen
berichte ich mich wenn es falsch ist
aber locker schon ein halbes jahr oder
länger weil hat noch mal nur einen alten
pc und ist ein ganz ganz eilig hatte
zwischendurch kurzzeitig ein windows pc
und alles ist habt ihr aber nicht alles
mitbekommen
den hatte ich echt sehr sehr lange man
ältere pc wartet mal die erste folge
weil ich weiß nicht wann die erste folge
aus cham ist auf jeden fall schon länger
her und dann war es halt am anfang sind
dass ihr mir ich habe direkt in der
ersten folge gesagt ihr könnt effekt
schreiben die serie lebt von euch und
von euren facts und ich habe auch glaube
ich eine erste folge sagt es kann sein
dass es gibt schon mehrere videos davon
es gibt schon videos über fact in
minecraft es gibt schon englische videos
minecraft so was halt alles was halt
leute das auch so erklärt haben was
passiert wenn man bestimmte dinge in
minecraft macht so allerdings ist es bei
mir dazu gewesen
so warte ja das ist richtig das ist park
also das ist das soll überhaupt nicht
gegen spa geben erst mal war das ist das
stemmen dann ja auch viele leute das
park hat dann irgendwie als ich dann bei
folge bauweise nicht mehr welcher folge
war ich dabei folge ziehen mit den fans
oder folge folge 8 oder so oder sieben
ich weiss es nicht ist ja auch relativ
irrelevant da hat's parkt dann auch so
eine art der reis sein haus ab scansafe
das wollen sonst gebaut oder macht nur
hier vorne sein haus rein
na ja gut ich bis jetzt erstmal da so
hin
man hat halt auch diese serie minecraft
facts angefangen so alles schön und gut
allerdings die meine serie natürlich
weiter ich habe dann zugesagt so haye
macht jetzt auch blabla dies das normale
vernünftige oder altbewerber bisschen
geschrieben so was allerdings meinten
dann diese zieren die sonne
das geht doch durch hier warum ist ihr
denn soweit im endeffekt ich dann meine
serie natürlich weiterhin davon gelebt
dass ihr mir sachen in die kommentare
geschrieben hat und per e-mail et cetera
und dann vertraue ich natürlich darauf
als was heißt ich vertraue darauf ich
schaue natürlich schon dass die ganzen
sachen da stimmen dass das alles
vernünftig zugeht dass die ganzen sachen
also es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich in
einer aufnahme gehe und dann sagt sie ja
das wird mir zu wie macht das denn und
das man sieht ja gar nicht ich bereite
mich da natürlich darauf vor allerdings
kann ich natürlich nicht alle von
sexvideos durchgehen weil er immer fünf
sachen vorstellung irgendwie alle zwei
tage sondern so einfällt sie gemacht
dazu habe ich keine zeit
deswegen hat nämlich mittlerweile schon
in der folge immer wieder überholt
glaube ich da habe ich mir dann einfach
gedacht gut so viel zeit habe ich nicht
dazu oft hochzuladen
dann soll er das machen ich schaff das
nicht ich habe weiterhin gesagt dass ich
komplett auf eure e mails habe ruhe und
dass ich mich dass deswegen das demnach
dann defekts vorstellte soll dann ich
stelle meine facts vor blabla die mir
per e-mail drinnen wurde teste dass ein
paar sachen stellt das video halt vor
laut das video jetzt letztes hoch
effektiven schutz von sparkle cloud die
stars anna bligh da fallen mir natürlich
dann erstmal hält was soll das dann wird
mir gesagt dass ich was geklaut hätte
obwohl das grundstück ich weiß nicht wo
man über die bäume ab obwohl ihr mir die
sachen per e-mail gesendet habt dann
schickt mir noch nicht die sachen per e
mail die augsburg schreibt das ist ja
schon gezeigt hat das ist ja nicht der
sinn der sache
wir wollen nicht vernünftig wir andere
sachen vorstellen ist natürlich jetzt
durch das bad auch die serie machte
somit sehr viele fakes quasi
ich sag mal vorweg nimmt aber es ist da
ja nicht meine schuld ich nehme nur
effektiv ist ihr könnt mir nicht zumuten
dass ich wenn ich abends um acht oder
mal zu hause bin und dann sähe am
montagmorgen musste facts folge kommen
könnt ihr mir nicht zumuten dass ich an
alle millionen videos bei youtube
checken soll ob das nicht schon
irgendwie vorgestellt hat so also sollte
jetzt nicht in spa kings park macht
seine serie ich mal meinen seine
pleiteserie
ich hatte die zuerst nein das ist jetzt
egal das ist pippifax die sache das muss
man nicht so sagen aber es ist halt doof
dass wir genau die gleichen sachen
zugesendet werden die wohl in spark
videos dann schon vorgekommen sind
ich will da nix clown es tut mir leid
wenn es irgendwie so rüberkommt und es
tut mir leid wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen
ausraster welche kommentare sehe du
[ __ ] ich [ __ ] deine mutter du hast
den effekt schon von spark geklaut trägt
mich voller verletzter richtig oft und
so da kann ich doch nichts für was kann
meine mutter dafür dass hat jedoch wenn
ihr mir die sachen schickt naja ich
verstehe nicht wie man menschen so
angehen muss das regt mich dann immer
auf wenn der andere leute eingezogen
denn die nächst damit zu tun haben naja
gut so zweite sache absetzung von mir
glaube ich erst mal die nächste folge
werde ich mit denen aufnehmen die
nächsten beiden
also dann werde ich da nicht mehr
alleine sein möchte
behindert so wichtig nehmen
diese kann ich denn das ding nicht
nehmen ich bekomme hier seien schall
staub oder wieso kommt ihnen nicht
nehmen
er werde direkt daran naja gut nächste
sache also das war erstmal das mit den
effekt da tut mir leid dass es manchmal
so rüberkommt dass ich mich da immer und
immer wieder darüber aufregt ist auch
immer so dass immer und immer wieder
diese kommentare kommen
also ich kann nicht jedes einzelne video
weltweit immer kontrollieren und ich
hab's park auch nicht abonniert und auf
defekt von ihm nicht gerade deswegen
dass so etwas nicht vorkommt damit ich
noch nicht irgendwas von ihnen dann
verwende besser deswegen ich verstehe
dass da nicht warum man dann außerdem so
hart auch angegangen wird also das finde
ich ein bisschen doof bisschen komisch
aus müsste es echt cool wenn immer
sondern scrooge treppe kommt aber gut
die stadt hat mich vergessen zu holen so
die zweite sache die ich sagen wollte
war jetzt mit dem change accepted video
ich habe lange kein spanisch accepted
mir hochgeladen dass du noch leid aber
ich habe aber kämpft die türen zu kann
man echt durch meckern nicht gut ich
lass mal offen allerdings
ich hab mir jetzt wieder so gedacht hey
wieso letzte videos durchgecheckt so was
hast du bist ja eigentlich als hochladen
serien das wollte mal wieder sehen weil
ich habe lange zeit jetzt erstmal nur
hochladen hab war ich auch wirklich
wenig zeit den abiturvorbereitungen die
stars dann tut mir leid dass ich euch
das immer vorteile aber es ist halt
einfach so was anderes kann ich dazu
erhält nicht sagen was wollt ihr jetzt
holen diese teile von schulen und lars
pence pro jetzt noch nicht die sache war
als nur die dass ich jetzt endlich mal
gedacht habe solar challenge accepted
war ganz cool kam auch gut an wurde mir
auch viele kommentare runter geschrieben
das machen soll
und viele kommentare waren halt noch mal
winter handschuhe an und versucht zu
spielen
diese kommentare habe ich vor ca sieben
monaten bekommen soll
dann gucke ich heute ich war nicht zu
hause weil wegen ich war unterwegs ich
war bei dessen alle die mir auf
instagram folgen wissen was ich gegessen
habe in fact sheet in der beschreibung
fällt sie das nicht findet jedenfalls
war in essen und so kommen dann halt
nach hause doch dann so ja okay jetzt
noch ein bisschen vor
anhängerführerschein weil wenn ihr das
video gerade hier seht hatte ich schon
meine anhänger prüfen ich hoffe ich
hab's bestanden
cool das kontor das ist cool und ich
setze auch mal so ein paar fackel
einfachen jedenfalls dass ich ein
bisschen doof aus ist ja gar keinen
eingang
jetzt mache ich mein trainer wenn ich
das hinkriege in lucka sagt schöner ist
scheiße ich komme nach hause macht mir
ja das wird bestimmt gut ankommen dass
eine coole idee war einfach so mit mit
ganz dicken handschuhen zu spielen und
ich fand es auch gut die runde ich weiß
auch nicht so schlecht wie ich
eigentlich erwartet hätte natürlich ich
bin jetzt nicht der beste spieler
abzugeben
aber das geht ja direkt lang muss das ja
auch noch als ab
allerdings war es halt so dass da sehr
sehr viele kommentare drunter standen
die mich sehr sehr gekränkt haben und
zwar konnte bei den fans richtig immer
verteidigt hab ich dir immer geglaubt
hast du das nicht nicht bei kickers aber
jetzt auf einmal das hatten doch schon
mal gemacht oder termiten ich weiß es
nicht ich glaube er ist deutscher ich
habe gute aber nicht abonniert und auch
noch nicht geschaut
ich kann jetzt nichts zu sagen
allerdings stand halt sehr viele
kommentare ich hätte das von dieser ob
ich hasse diese schaufeln dies so heftig
allerdings meinten halt viele leute ich
hätte es von dieser person geklaut weil
diese person das ihm wie auch schon mal
gemacht hat jedenfalls ich dann erstmal
in den kommentaren geantwortet nee
stimmt nicht ich hab die kommentare also
ich hab wirklich diesen kommentar dass
ich das mal mit handschuhen spielen soll
habe ich vor sieben monaten acht monaten
oder so habe ich eine e-mail in meinem
postfach kann ich euch auf den
screenshots zeigen wenn ich mir jetzt
nicht so glaubt habe ich dann schon e
mails bekommen alles mögliche das erste
mal machen soll habe es halt nicht
umgesetzt weil ich damals dachte da fing
sogar megaprojekt an und so bei während
sap titel komm mach erst mal mega
projekt deswegen habe ich das halt nicht
gemacht erst mal so dann jetzt habe ich
das halt gemacht und jetzt mal alle
wieder ja du hast den vollkommen
verloren geklettert da schon vor jahren
gemacht vor jahrzehnten hat er schon
gemacht und du bist nur noch am klauen
und so blabla und haben dann halt wieder
beleidigt so deine mudda alles möglich
so richtig wickelt böse sachen die ich
gar nicht will dass meine familie der
überhaupt mit reingezogen wird da dazu
kann ich auch noch was sagen also keine
auslands folge wenn ihr sowas nicht
schreibt dann seid ihr nicht betroffen
liebe ich euch aber solche leute es
einfach nur abschalten möchte nicht
hierbei haben einfach das mag ich gar
nicht erst mal
es gibt bestimmt noch mehr leute auf der
welt die bestimmt irgendwann mal
irgendwas mit handschuhen gemacht haben
obwohl man es normalerweise nicht mit
haben schon macht ich weiß nicht gerecht
als kein beispiel nehmen
aber erstmal er findet nie etwas neues
man macht meine findet nie etwas neu das
ist nahezu unmöglich
jetzt auf youtube youtube technisch
gesehen da kommst du das jetzt ich mache
das jetzt mal bot das ist heftig zurück
einmal drauf und teilweise gehen zwei
blöcke auf kaputt man kann nie was neues
machen sagt jedenfalls habe ich bestimmt
nicht
lutens video gesehen und mir dann
gedacht
das merkt bestimmt keiner wenn ich das
noch mache dann mach ich doch einfach
mal nach stande ist ja relativ egal dann
die menschen die sind ja alle blöd meine
zuschauer ja jetzt bei so ein paar
leuten denke auch dass sie jetzt blöd
sind aber dass mir dann wieder
unterstellt wird von dem man dem geklaut
ich habe diese person nicht abonniert
wird der kommt ja schon so lange
zugesehen ich hab das erst in minecraft
change accepted video vor ca weiß nicht
6 monaten von einem halben jahr
hochgeladen
keine ahnung und alle meinen auf einmal
wie kriege ich denn daraus jetzt diesen
anderen stein teltscher ich glaub ich
hab jetzt kein bock zu suchen
ich baue jetzt einfach partie kurz im
sektor unter allgemein packe man eben
alles runter ich gar nicht doch damit
ich da ein paar sachen davon kann das
ist cool aber kann man immer so
durchziehen
so und es ist bestimmt nicht meine
absicht gewesen dass sich dann von
dieser person irgendwie das geklaut habe
so von wegen
war das auch schon gemacht aber ich dass
man auch da ich weiß nicht wie viele
abonnenten er hat aber bestimmt keiner
so nach dem motto das war bestimmt nicht
meine absicht und wenn man mir sowas
unterstellt dann werde ich echt schick
ich ihn kenne das möchte ich einfach
nicht sehen weil ich will nicht dass
leute klauen und ich wirklich dass ich
will auch nicht dass ich von irgendwas
klar deswegen tut mir leid wenn ich
wette der vermuten hat nichts dagegen
ich hätte da wird jetzt nicht sagen so
wie ihr orden [ __ ] der familie
cloud wird er nicht daran genauso wie es
park und ich gut miteinander auskommen
in den kommentaren immer gesagt so
weissbarth das hat kann ich schon mal
vorgestellt und conny das als back schon
mal vorgestellt und blablabla wenn ihr
mir so etwas schreibt also jetzt auf das
change accepted video habe kann ich
jetzt ganz von mir aus so sagen ja es
wurde schon viel früher geschrieben ich
hab's noch nicht umgesetzt und ich habe
bestimmt nicht gedacht so oder so etwas
schon mal geschrieben das jetzt gemacht
so ob ich das mal einfach so nach dem
motto nämlich nicht das war nicht
einfach so viel zu sehen ich bin mal
wieder in die kommentare gegangen in die
e mails gecheckt und dann hab ich
gesehen so ganz alte e mails für change
accepted kann man ja so suchen
yao blabla das ganz cool kann immer
machen zwar soll ich das gemacht
also ich glaube kann übrigens auch
komplett falsch 64 habe ich also war das
nämlich also da tut mir leid ein paar
luton und an alle die mir das
unterstellen
ganz ohne scheiß ich finde es traurig
dass mir so etwas unterstellt wird
naja gut zu der sache mit spark dass da
eventuell mal ein paar sachen sind die
irischen vorgestellt aber es gibt nahezu
keine großartig heftigen sachen mehr die
man vorstellen kann minecraft ist ein
paar sachen die eventuellen slapshot
noch hinzugefügt hat oder aber
dann schreibt mir doch einfach auch
vernünftige sachen und nicht so was wie
das forschen vorangestellt menschen
schießt dann auf die leute die mir das
zugeschickt haben weil ich schaue es
park nicht ich gucke nur die kommentare
das ist eine serie die komplette bei
euch läuft deswegen naja erstmal dazu
ich hoffe ihr glaubt mir jetzt wenn ihr
mir nicht glaubt dann de abonniert mich
einfach ganz einfach das ist ein knopf
können einfach drauf drücken dann könnt
ihr mich ist nicht neu das nächste cup
träumen ohne witz ich hasse diese bäume
wenn ich könig wäre zuvor diese bäume
abhaken
ich wollte mal wieder mit schoko babo
reden mal schauen was sie davon hält so
zuckerberg
meine heilige könige was halten sie
davon dass alle leute mir immer zu
unrecht unterstellt ich hätte das eher
da geklaut und das da
wir sind also diese großartige
verkündung hallo ich bin so kaputt geht
tobago
was hältst du davon ja wie halt war
schon gesagt finde das cool und findet
es nicht cool von den leuten wichtig
ohne scheiß ich frage des coo von leuten
eine gute entscheidung von den modulen
so etwas ist eigentlich so weitermachen
wird behindert naja ich glaube ich
kandidiere bald als könig einfach nur um
die königin danach zu töten ja ich
glaube ich hat echten plan was ich mache
jetzt diese panne voll auf meinem
grundstück emmely hier kein platz mehr
so ist im weg zwei plätze leben
32 mal diese blöden bäumen die sind so
grotten eklig ich hasse die ich sehen
richtig beschreibt meine kommentare
findet die bäume schöne da findet ihr
hier herzlich jetzt nicht sagen
nein ich werde hier herzlich aber käfer
die gebaute kämpfe school nicht so
sondern so wichtig leute zum beispiel
die gebäude aber finden die kohle da
nicht schwer denn ich mag die irgendwie
gar nicht so jetzt sind wir bei 18
minuten ich hab die komplett über
nachmachen geredet ich hoffe dass
verstanden es tut mir leid falls ich da
ein bisschen ausgerastet bin aber es
muss jetzt einfach mal gesagt werden
wenn sowas kommt ihr wisst meine meinung
dazu ihr wisst die wahrheit wenn er es
denn glaubt man ja ich bin so
unzufrieden am liebsten richtig richtig
kleines haus am liebsten die wirklich so
ein kleines haus
ich habe eine richtig geile idee aber
dafür muss ich echt viele sachen
abreißen
egal ich mache das jetzt einfach in
dieser folge und in der nächsten folge
mit denen werde ich so ein bisschen haus
bauen weiter und zwar ich hab coole
ideen ich werde mich sonnenklar ich das
noch nicht
ich weiß noch nicht was man ideen sind
aber ich denke es wird auf jeden fall
sehr cool was ich hier vor habe
wenn es denn so funktioniert nicht mir
das vorstelle ich raten ob das
funktionieren könnte brauche da etwas
für die erste klappe dann brauche ich ja
das klappt auf jeden fall ja das muss
auch weg leider nicht weglaufen
das pack ich dann dahin
da soll man kann nächste sachen das
längste bauwerk tunnel zuschauer aber
ganz schön krass so dann brauche ich da
vorne noch etwas und da ja das sollte
eigentlich laufen
das sollte sogar richtig cool werden
wenn jetzt so wie ich mir das was ich
mag den stil in unserer stadt doch
eigentlich nicht dieses dunkel
naja kann man bestimmt etwas cooles wort
bauen so ihr kommt hier erst mal
komplett weg ich bin mal 20 minuten
ja freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat was
heißt gefallen ist war eigentlich doof
weil ich einfach nur meine meinung
gesagt habe was auch echt mal bitter
nötig war
freunde dann lass doch einfach mal ich
will es dieses bildet nämlich das nicht
noch mal machen muss
wenn ihm einer meinung seid oder wenn
ihr das nachvollziehen können oder wenn
ihr selbst schon die erfahrung mit
solchen kommentaren gemacht habe wenn
ihr auch videos macht dann lasst einfach
eine bewertung dar und schreibt mir auch
meine kommentare und ich denke die
folgen wir sehr viel hält bekommen der
nächsten folge in den nächsten beiden
oder drei folgen wieder mit dabei sein
da werde ich die mein haus ein bisschen
weiter bauen und ich werde versuchen
mein aluminium mal hier drin zu
schmelzen und den erfragen aber weiß wie
das geht ich weiß nicht ob eine seine
herzen kanister geschenkt bekommen hat
oder ob er die selbst gemacht hat
deswegen frage ich ihn einfach mal was
funktioniert und sonst würd ich sagen
freunde geht es morgen weiter oder es
geht
es geht sogar heute abend noch mit einem
video weiter und zwar was es sein wird
weiß ich nicht ich weiß noch nicht ob
sollte damit ein video weitergeht ich
hoffe mal ja